ten year anniversary if you had to plan
a big party for that gathering what kind
of party would you throw I'd probably
like do a throwback like solo cup house
party right like just just go back would
you be down to do some sort of reunion
with the hills cast I've heard rumblings
of that I would definitely be down I
think it would be fun yeah I was just
depending on the opportunity I mean it
would be cool to also see where
everybody's lives are at and now that
we're all like grown up and everybody's
got pretty big interesting lives yes I
didn't reveal of the producer of the
hills sent me a text for the first time
in a while and he said that that a movie
was like greenlit on Netflix or what's
Netflix or something like that and kind
of want everybody in and it was the
first time in a long time I was like
yeah let's do it
I feel like give you now is a good
enough time I know that there was some
problems about it but I don't think it's
happening yet anyway
so it would be great to do it so it
would it would be nice to see them all
together just even in a reunion like
director's chairs I thought it'd be
interesting I think it would be amazing
family and this is really fun
I am so game for a reunion I think it
would be a ton of fun we are all in such
different places in our lives no we're
getting married him it was having babies
so we'll see but I think it I think it
would be fun I would I would